And now for those steps.
First, we drag a table into
the view from the object menu.
It'll automatically expand
to fill the whole view.
You'll want to drag this upper border
down a bit so that it ends up a.
Below the status bar.
Next we bring up the constraints menu,
and add constraints for the borders.
And once the table's in place,
we can connect the data source.
So Ctrl-click on the table to open
up the pop-up connections menu.
Then you can drag from this data source
property to the view controller icon.
You're probably familiar
with those steps by now.
Here come the two new steps.
Add a cell to the table by going
to the attributes inspector, and
setting prototype cells to one.
If you click on the cell,
you'll see it needs a reuse identifier.
Let's go into the project navigator so
we can double check what the cell was
called in the Villan view controller.
Here you can see the VillanCell.
Is being dequeued.
So, here we can see our reuse
identified to be VillainCell.
By the way, when you're
entering text into these cells.
Make sure you always hit return.
Otherwise storyboard won't save it.
This is weird behavior, and the source
of a lot of frustration for both new and
accomplished developers.
And those are the steps for
setting up a table view in storyboard.
So let's run it and see how it looks.
So you can see that the pictures and
names are there, but
not the evil schemes.
That's because of the cell style.
If you go back into
the attributes inspector,
you will see this drop
down menu labeled style.
Here you can see your options for
cell styles, and
we'll have more details on
that in the next section.